they're not bad words no werth are bad
but some people start using them a lot
to hurt other people and then they
become bad they become a hard to you
there's words that I love that I can use
cuz other people use them wrong to hurt
other people like the word cunt is a
beautiful word to me there's just beauty
in that word it has it's like chocolatey
and round on the ends I just like them I
just like the way it sounds and I don't
use it as an inside been I'm alone in
the laundry oh my god
[Music]
words hold a lot of weight when you give
a guy a foot massage in particular swear
words fuck you while people may just
consider them a way to make something
funny or to show someone's mat it
actually goes a lot deeper than I want
to explore swear words see how they're
used and how they reveal a lot more than
you may think
- no we're swearing came from one has to
look no further than the word itself the
word swearing and cursing are biblical
in origin the first words that were
taboo were words that said the Lord's
name in vain way back in the day
swearing on the Bible was a big deal
because people really thought perjury
undetected by the legal system would be
punished by an eavesdropping and easily
offended God did you swear to tell the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth clapping ah yes similarly a
curse on someone was not only serious
but also deadly nowadays our society has
lessons the power of those vulgarities
and focused more on the taboos of sex
and bodily functions but I think it's a
common misconception to think we've
become completely desensitized from
swear words in the 21st century sure
plenty of movies swear like crazy but
swear words still hold that element of
taboo to prove my point would this line
have had the same effect if it was I
haven't made love this intensely people
may associate swearing with somebody
who's out of control swearing in rage
but what's interesting in cinema is that
it can often be the opposite
the person who swears is the one that's
actually in control of the scene Jerry
Lundegaard in Fargo is constantly sworn
out by people he hires a fucking wife
you know are you fucking wife scary
strangers here a bald-faced liar a
fucking liar and his own son looked here
there's no fucking way and when he gets
pushed too far he finally curses back
but it's hilariously lame
you're darn Tooting
damned important oh yeah he's an
extremely weak character who constantly
gets pushed around and the swear words
revealed how everyone in his life can
talk down to him and control him the one
who's swearing is the one dominating
this scene it's almost like a verbal way
of marking your territory you'll notice
in the opening of Reservoir Dogs that
mr. white is the only one who gets to
swear directly at the boss showing not
only that they have a more casual
relationship but that mr. white is
willing to stand up - in my book I'm
fucking here jog your back you won't
swear words carry a lot of weight the
most famous line in cinema would not be
the same without the swear a much bigger
deal back in 1939 the curse word really
embodies how fed up red is with starlet
O'Hara and he's not bubbling in anger
it's pure apathy a place where swearing
his controversial is actually stand-up
comedy there's that age-old debate of
vulgarity and whether or not comedians
could be just as funny without the
constant svox and the glasses just
completely disguises this guy and then
it was something about meantime two of
them are stuck in a fucking cave every
week you know and that was the bit and
then I said well let me see if it works
without the word right and I took the
word out didn't work and that's what
bothered me and why do comedians swing
but it's not about the swear word there
it's about you to get in the world oh no
it's about you getting worked up about
it about this guy's he means this he's
so annoying right the fucking cave
you're as funny that's contempt you're
the cave take for example this swear
word that's always bothered me in the
Titanic fuckin hand it serves no purpose
and it's a poor use of vulgarity it
definitely makes anything funny it does
there's no doubt about it once you once
you inject a fuck into your speech it
makes it funnier it gives it it gives it
an emphasis and it gives it a shot just
about every swear word in The Departed
seems to make me laugh Queen is on the
gun and I'd be kidding myself if
sometimes I swear words purpose is just
as simple as that but in the movie they
don't just swear left and right
characters know when it's appropriate or
not like using a softer word when
flirting with someone you just met
they'll have fun they're all freaking
crazy
but once you've got her interest then
you can go in for the sweat when is the
last time you checked before I went to
find a topic and this is 40 Melissa
McCarthy essentially cameos as the
character that swears non-stop and it's
just dumb don't get me wrong I love a
good improvised moment and swear words
can be really funny but this scene makes
no sense in its context Jill this is why
everybody hates you Jill this kind of
shit I mean they're in a principal's
office and they just met and she's gonna
talk like this it's not realistic and
frankly it's boring none of this talk is
productive but how about this let's try
something a little more complex
what is this swear word accomplish now
then Tommy what did he mix say to you
multiple names in the next cell he said
I can smell your cunt I see this use of
swearing has many layers to it at first
it seems like a way to make Clarice
uncomfortable Hannibal obviously heard
what make said and he just wants her to
have to say it so she's embarrassed but
with every insult and humiliating
comment he spits at her she stays strong
continuing to act polite and sincere she
a lot doctor I think it's partly
Hannibal's admiration for her strength
and a sense of pity that causes him to
help her at the end of the scene there's
a certain duality - swear words on one
hand they're funny but on the other hand
they're deadly nothing captures this
idea more than movies like Full Metal
Jacket and whiplash where authority
figures yellow verbal abuse that's funny
but also deeply manipulative come over
to my house and fuck my sister I know
that's a lot of ways to use swear words
but what ties them all together is that
a swear word always reveals something it
reveals control a relationship or even
some manipulation there's that saying
sticks and stones may break my bones but
words may never hurt me after watching
this video do you still think that's
true
maybe maybe not maybe fuck yourself
slightly transformed just a bit of a
break from the norm just a little
something to break the monotony of all
that hard